hi i'm bella murphy my dad is eddie
murphy
and today i'm gonna do i'm gonna rate
some of his clothes on the kelly
clarkson show
i like this picture i like the suit i
think that's fun
um hmm i like this outfit i like the
leather pants
he did that a lot i'm realizing the
leather pants i'm realizing but um
i guess i would give i don't know maybe
a 10 i don't know
i give it a 10. i like this this is fun
this reminds me of like axel holy for
some reason i like it
um i i'm gonna i'm just gonna keep
saying tense i like these outfits
they're fun i like i like um vintage
stuff
like all like 80s clothing and 90s
clothing is really fun
for me and i always steal from that era
so
yeah okay this one is better than the
other ones obviously
but i like this one i like the necklace
that's fun
the leather suit i've never seen this
black one
but i like it um
we're gonna give this one an 11. we're
just gonna keep going higher and higher
and higher
this one okay
we'll give this one an eight
[Music]
it's still a great outfit but i'm just
comparing it i'm just comparing it
because i don't want to say
10 10 10 10 the whole time i'm just
comparing it to the other ones
i think the other ones are a little
better but still a great outfit
love the red tie fun there's no [ __ ]
there's no shirt
there's only pants and a hat but uh fun
still
the the no shirt seems like it's an
artistic choice
so maybe i'd give it um
a nine because it's fun the red hat
matches
it's fun i like the adidas pants
i like i like the glove and i like the
watch i like the
the whole shirt actually that's really
cool i like that i'm gonna give it a 10.
definitely a pen or an 11. that's a good
outfit
he had really good style i'm gonna start
like ripping things
i like the blue good choice good choice
good choice
nice blue i like that i'm giving it a
10. i don't even have to think on this
one it's a 10
and the glasses are nice it's a 10
solid you know i just realized or i
learned the other day
that my dad's mustache is like an iconic
thing i didn't know that
like that people were like oh yeah the
mustache i was like oh i didn't i didn't
even know that
but i like this shirt i would wear that
shirt that's a nice shirt
um we're gonna give this one
9.5 i love the 80s so much like i wish i
could
okay i love this um this is fun
i like this outfit i like the i don't
even know how to describe it it's like a
but i don't know how to describe that
80s like jacket that
i'm seeing but i've seen it like
multiple times it's i don't know how to
describe it but i like the jacket that's
my point
and um i like the belt i like the tie
thing right there that he tied it that's
cool
it a 10. it's just so 80s and amazing
and i love it i just it's a good outfit
like it's fun
it's a nice throwback i like it thank
you guys so much for having me on the
kelly clarkson show make sure you guys
go check it out
and yeah thank you guys for watching
this is amazing
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure